yup movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the very best karate
kid easter eggs epic call backs and
hidden details you might have missed in
the third season of cobra kai
spoilers ahead of corso take care before
they came up with eagle fang as the name
for johnny's new dojo
welcome to eagle fang karate eagles
don't have thanks
the show's writers tossed around various
suggestions from different animals that
his character would think of as
representing strength and masculinity
including lions
the final idea came from johnny's 80s
mentality and the eagle that he has on
the wall of his apartment
and i imagine something that also
influenced the name was johnny's love of
a particular 80s military action movie
that we see him watch repeatedly
what are your likes i like muscle cars
and iron eagle and aren't eagle too
as for the fang part of the dojo title
the showrunners say that's just
consistent with johnny's ignorance and
he thinks it sounds badass
you gotta swoop down like an eagle grab
em with your claws and sink your fangs
into them when the country club's
kitchen staff start dishing out
spaghetti and red sauce i'll skip on
that sauce it sets up a call back to the
original karate kid movie where daniel
gets covered in that same food after
bumping into a waiter when he sneaks
into the country club kitchen
and sees johnny kissing ally on the
dance floor this time though the boots
on the other foot as it's johnny who
arrives at the club for a date with ally
to find her and daniel together but
luckily for him
unlike young daniel adult johnny
narrowly avoids a run-in with the red
sauce
hey watch it i'm wearing white here you
think i want that all over me
and when johnny makes fun of daniel's
suit his rivals come back
you should talk their scarface is a
reference to al pacino's famous movie
role as penniless cuban tony montana who
became a drug lord nicknamed scarface in
1980s miami
the way ali greets daniel when she sees
him for the first time in decades at the
country club
daniel with an l is a nod to this scene
in the original movie
hey you got a name ally with an eye hey
what's your name
daniel with an elf and tori does a
similar thing in season two her name's
miguel
dory
with a y when the larussos invite cobra
kai's landlord over for dinner to ask
him to stop renting the dojo to crease
the camera starts the scene by focusing
in on a dish of macaroni and cheese
macaroni and cheese hey you know what i
like
i grew up on macaroni and cheese i never
say no when it comes to macaroni and
cheese the skeleton hoodie tori wears
during cobra kai's bruce or payback
attack on miyagidou is a hat tip to the
skeleton costumes johnny and his crew
wore to the halloween dance and while
they were beating up daniel afterwards
and getting their butts kicked by mr
miyagi in the original movie
and that skeleton costume actually
popped up in season one when johnny gave
it to miguel to wear for his halloween
dance and like johnny all those years
earlier miguel also ended up in a fight
that night
in both the tv show and the original
movie the beef between kobe kai and
miyagido
also plays out on the soccer pitch
dimitri deliberately trips hawk
up just like bobby did to daniel in the
first movie and curiously the music you
hear during the match in the series is
rock and roll overview which featured in
the second movie's ice breaking scene
one of the fun things about cobra kai is
getting to see parts of the karate kid
movies from a different perspective
tell them how they pushed you down that
hill i thought it was a cliff and it
seems like there's a shout out at the
school board meeting to the popular
satirical youtube video by j
matthew turner about dany being the real
villain of the karate kid
when i went to school here i was bullied
and karate saved me
i heard you were the real bully that's
also a nod to the first season where
johnny claimed to miguel that he was
victimized by daniel
out of nowhere the guy sucker punches
yeah yeah what an [ __ ]
i know man though this season daniel
gives miguel his version of events
all that i knew is that he broke her
radio she was upset i was being
chivalrous
and speaking of different sides to the
story it turns out that daniel's reason
for his and ally's breakup
she tells me that she's just fallen in
love with some football player from ucla
was rather different to ali's version so
i got into ucla
and i ran into this guy that i knew who
went there
daniel sees me talking to my friend he
jumps to conclusions
i thought you were in love with the guy
and they didn't see eye to eye on
daniels 47 ford either with daniel
complaining to mr miyagi that
first they let ali bar the car and she
redesigns my fender and i don't know
what you do with the engine but that
ain't running right either warehouse
according to ali
i told you that the brakes on mr
miyagi's car were gonna go
i hope he didn't tell him that it was my
fault it crashed
no of course not and when ali calls
daniel and johnny out over their
relentless bickering she neatly sums up
the premise of the entire cobra kai show
you say one thing and then you say the
opposite you both think there's only one
side of the story
there's your side and your side and then
there is
the truth talking of different
viewpoints the show continues to include
unused footage from the original movies
that's never been seen before
as they did in the very first scene in
season one this season
the flashbacks have chosen's final fight
with daniel when miyagi impresses on him
how serious the situation is
daniel's reply i know has been added to
the scene
it's not tournament it's for real i know
when daniel goes to kobrakai looking for
johnny at the start of the season but
finds crease there instead
as he enters the space he sees the
phrase fear does not exist in this dojo
painted on the wall where previously
johnny's cobra kai logo had been
those were creases very first words in
the original karate kid movie that dany
heard when he visited his jojo for the
first time
fear does not exist in this dojo
adding to dany's sense of deja vu is a
standee of the older crease
similar to the one he saw of the younger
villain in the film
in the present day crease delights in
rubbing in the fact miguel was put in a
coma by a kid taught by daniel
and he uses a mr miyagi-ism to make the
point
but i don't really blame robbie because
you know what they say
there's no such thing as a bad student
no such thing
a bad student only bad teacher season
three fills us in on creases backstory
and the first flashback to his youth is
deliberately set up to make us think at
first that this
guy here is actually the young priest
they're the opponent
we don't show them mercy and it's only
when the busboy's employer shouts at him
that we realize who he really is
chris his tables are not gonna bust
himself get back to work
and a neat little inside joke that adds
to this scene's fake out is that the guy
we initially think is crease is in fact
played by jesse cove the son of actor
martin cove who plays the adult crease
the showrunners initially framed crease
as a typical underdog as they wanted us
to see him in a different light because
as they told ew
one of the show's central themes is
redemption and looking back at these
black and white characters and trying to
find the grey
another neat detail about that scene is
that it kicks off with the same kind of
car that mr miyagi gifted daniel in the
first film a 47
ford piece of junk scrap this and buy
some muscle
although the license plate is different
to daniels i wouldn't be surprised if
they're supposed to be the same car
perhaps saved from the scrapyard after
all that's how eric got his ride in the
franchise's fourth film
do you like my car i saved it from the
junkyard the old article about crease
from the 80s that robbie finds online
includes a quote from him that
second and third place don't count which
echoes his mantra from the first film
defeat does not exist in his dojo and
recalls his treatment of johnny in the
second one
second place has no place you're off and
as we see in the finale when he suggests
settling everything in the tournament
crease is still goading johnny about
that second place back in 84
all these years later because notice how
he looks at johnny when he says
if you lose if you lose we won't lose
and the second article that robbie pulls
up about how miyagi's dojo defanged
crease's cobras has the same title as
the newspaper clipping that crease
picked up then tossed aside in the third
movie
speaking of johnny's facebook photos
those shirtless shots that miguel
tactfully turns down for sensei's new
profile
are actually real photos taken of
william zabka for teen magazines during
his days as a teen
idol the showrunners had been ready to
recreate a few shots but as zapka had
some photos on hand that worked they
went with those
when chosen fur shows up his angry
demeanor suggests he's still holding a
grudge against daniel for humiliating
him in the second film and you can tell
by daniel's clenched fist that he hasn't
forgotten mr miyagi's words
in okinawa ana have no time limit
and the way chosen interrupts daniel and
kumiko just after their hands lightly
brush against each other at the bar
mirrors how in the movie he disturbed
them just as they started to hold hands
on their date
with actor yuji okamoto back has chosen
the show tips its hat to several of his
and daniel's tussles from the sequel
including humorously reversing their
roles in their big fight scene compared
to the movie
and later when chosen gives daniel one
of mr miyagi's scrolls
you keep for your correction that's a
riff on the scene in the movie where
kumi ko pelt's chosen with the tomato
after he attacks daniel
you keep for your correction i know you
like it
when chosen shows daniel around his dojo
you can see several pictures there that
are the same ones as daniel hung up in
his dojo last season
in fact this photo here is actually a
real-life martial artist from okinawa
who founded the gujuri's school of
karate
and it's especially fitting that he
appears in the show because robert mark
cayman who created the original karate
kid characters and wrote the first three
movies
trained in that particular method and
his instructor learned it from the
founder himself whose photo we see here
during their catch-up in okinawa kumiko
reveals why london's the favorite place
she's visited over the years
i got to see the cranberries open for
radiohead they played
zombie linga and dream that's a nod to
the franchise's fourth movie the next
karate kid where hilary swank's
character julie practices her karate
moves to the sounds of the cranberry
song dreams and the monks at the
buddhist monastery where she's staying
join in dancing
never trust spiritual leader who cannot
dance
and when kumiko tells daniel that she
never married but stayed
a free agent that's a reference to how
daniel told her he was single in the
movie
are you ready what are you kidding i'm
afraid but it's rich it just means that
i'm available
curiously after she left the dance
company her life somewhat parallels her
aunt yuki's who taught obon dance in
okinawa and chose not to wed after her
young love mr miyagi left
why are you never married you never come
back
i'm supposed to believe that a guy never
got a ring on that finger
none of them fought to the death for me
which is of course a reference to how
chosen took her hostage to force daniel
to fight him
tracy taguchi who played the little girl
yoona in the second film also returns
and just as daniel saved her during the
typhoon all those decades ago thanks to
her position as the senior vice
president of sales for doyona she's able
to return the favor and help daniel save
his business
also during daniel's trip to okinawa
there's an amusing shout out to the
scene in the karate kid part 2 where the
young daniel broke
six blocks of ice in a bet this time
though the ice is just for drinks at a
bar
season two already tipped its hat to
that famous scene when daniel was about
to perform a demonstration to encourage
new miyagido students when he was
interrupted by kobra kai's showy a demo
with fire
crease may have kicked johnny out of his
own dojo at the end of season two
but in the first episode of the new
season we see that johnny is still
taking a page out of kris's book
this time he's putting his fist through
car windows during a fight
just like crease did back in the karate
kid part 2.
and it's not just car windows that get
smashed this season as during their
fight in the finale
crease throws daniel through a window
pane at the kobra kai dojo a call back
to when he turned up out of the blue at
the start of season 2 and ended up
kicking johnny into one of the dojo
mirrors
all of which is a nod to mr miyagi's
fight with kris and his army pal silva
and the karate kid part 3.
oh and just to confirm how much kobrakai
are taking after their new sensei the
final episode
also shows the cobra kids throwing bert
through the kitchen window at the
larusso home
when chris starts to choke johnny during
their final face-off that's a call back
to what he did in the second film
he has actually had johnny in a
chokehold in the series before now
though he was giving a demo in a class
at the time
rather than trying to beat him up given
he's such a fan of the iron eagle movie
it's no wonder johnny takes miguel to a
gig by d
snyder this season after all we're not
going to take it a song by snyder's
former heavy metal band twisted sister
features in that film
and the kobrakai series itself used the
same song in season one during johnny's
unconventional training with his
students for the tournament
when miguel takes photos of johnny for
his facebook page look at the book he's
pretending to read it's called
queen of hearts which is fitting because
johnny's having these photos taken to
impress his former teen
love ally but also the books about two
longtime
friends who are forced to reassess their
lives when an old flame returns out of
the blue
now daniel and johnny may not be friends
exactly but they do go way back and
their old flame alley turning up all of
a sudden does force them to confront the
truth about their past and themselves
you guys are more alike than you want to
admit after the car wash fundraiser the
cobra kai bullies wait for nathaniel to
be by himself on his push bike
then arrive on their motorbikes to beat
him up which is a throwback to when
johnny and his cobra kai buds got daniel
when he was alone on his bicycle and
roughed him up by driving him off the
track with their motorbikes after the
big fight between the kids at golf and
stuff
amanda confronts crease at his dojo hey
rambo
calling chris rambo of course fits his
tough aggressive character
and his vietnam background but it's also
a nod to the fact that actor martin cove
appeared in the second film in that
franchise
when daniel scrolling through family
photos on his phone at the bar in japan
i think this picture here is ralph macho
with his real-life daughter julia
and at the city council meeting this
looks like a cameo from macho's actual
son
daniel when the show first introduces
crease's army buddies everything about
this guy here
points to him being terry silva the main
villain in the third movie
from his ponytails to schaefer's face
his whole manner and the way he talks
johnny johnson hey johnny
johnny johnny so it's a bit of a shock
when he's killed off and the other guy
twig is revealed as the real silver
shut your goddamn mouth silver and twigs
line in the show
i owe you man echoes his words to crease
in the third movie
and now with chris's phone call in the
finale we look set to see the original
actor who played silva in the movie
thomas ian griffiths back on screen with
his cobra kai chum and i talked more
about that in my season
3 ending explained video tap here to
watch that or follow the link in the
video description
and it's also interesting how this
finale uses the classic 80s song in the
air tonight
to underscore the dramatic build up to
next season's showdown in a moment that
couldn't be more 1980s if he was wearing
an i heart the 80s hoodie and headband
the lyrics i've been waiting for this
moment all my life are especially
fitting and neatly meta
as not only has crease been craving
revenge for years but many fans of the
show have also been hoping for a team-up
between daniel and johnny
i also like the way the finale subtly
tips its hat to daniel and johnny's
showdown at the end of the first karate
kid film
by having daniel dressed in white and
johnny in black
so what other easter eggs call backs or
awesome details did you spot this season
and what was your favorite moment
comment below and if you enjoyed this
leave a thumbs up i really appreciate it
tap left for my next kobrakai video or
chat
right for something else you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time yippee kai
movie lovers